slowly they are regaining lost ground
backed by american airstrikes kurdish
peshmerga fighters say they have taken
back
two towns on the outskirts of aber
but the kurdish government says it's
just a start the peshmerga desperately
need military aid
the islamic state militants have
technically superior weapons
we ask our friends for support and
cooperation to provide us with the
necessary weapons to defeat these
terrorists
we welcome airstrikes and air support
for our peshmerga
air support is the only hope for
thousands of yasidi still trapped on
mount sinjar
witnesses say many have died they fled
to escape islamic state militias
who have surrounded the mountain and are
threatening to massacre them
an iraqi official said the islamists had
killed hundreds already
including some who were buried alive
women were also taken as slaves there is
no independent confirmation of these
allegations
reports suggest the peshmerga have led
tens of thousands of yasidi down mount
sinjar to safety
but politicians in baghdad are still
deadlocked
on sunday parliament was again unable to
choose a new prime minister